what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing on with DC's
drown to earth event and again like this
this whole drought earth concept deals
with like these other you know other
ocean Airy gods basically showing up on
earth and attacking it but again like we
don't explicitly know what their
motivations are it really seems to be
just kind of like inflicting chaos and
panic everywhere they go but they were
basically somebody here by Aquaman under
the auspices that he was essentially
summoning people who could serve as
aides of sorts because remember the
source walls fractured and it has been
ever since dark nights metal and so the
idea behind this was okay let's bring in
other forces out there who could help us
against whatever happens to come out of
the source wall and then just kind of go
from there the issue is that it's one of
these things were if you stare into the
abyss long enough eventually it stares
back out you know it stares back at you
and so it's one of these things where
Aquaman called on forces not fully
understanding what they were only to
realize that they were basically
villains now in their arrival basically
came this massive swelling of the oceans
in this invasion fleet that essentially
saw the transformation of all these
various beings that came into contact
with the water and that's why I think
he's are really kind of pop it off and
going not since because in Atlantis
proper with a brunt of the Kingdom
having been lifted up from the oceans to
kind of stand of this symbolic gesture
as a kind of a unification between the
Atlantean world and the and the human
world of course this leads to the to the
ocean being tainted and then just
transforming all these different people
in these various sea monsters now again
this is uh this is actually kind of cool
because at this point in time it's one
of the things to bear in mind is that
Mara is currently the queen of Atlantis
now this is something that I want to
talk about here for a second because
it's a pretty important thing when it
comes to the role of Mara and the
Aquaman mythos of course she's she's
usually depicted as this extremely
strong and capable wife of Aquaman but
as usually about the extent of it I mean
she has her own story she does her own
thing but historically speaking
Aquaman's been dethroned as the king of
Atlantis multiple times but it's always
kind of like a thing of its character
right like Batman is superman whenever
they first meet they always fight Dick
Grayson always rebelled against Batman
and always goes on to become Robin
whenever DC Reap reboots whatever the
case is but in the instance of Aquaman
he's dethroned and then he always takes
his throne back this is it's really only
a matter of time before that happens
Aquaman is not gonna remain kind of like
a departed king for a long time it's not
gonna be like the standard going forward
eventually he'll go back Mara will can
see the throne Aquaman will become key
again and that'll be that but at the end
the interim this is not something you
normally see you know merit
over in becoming queen of Atlantis for
any real measure of time it's it's not a
normal circumstance not only that what
it does is it actually shows a pretty
cool circumstance certain of in terms of
how she handles this because right now
Atlantis is in shambles it's literally
in pieces I mean these waters have just
kind of run amok across everything and
most people had no idea what was going
on and a lot of that was because of the
fact that Atlantis has and does continue
in a lot of ways to be segregated away
from like the surface world and so
because of the fact of this this attack
happened so astronomically fast because
it literally like sweeps across the
world like a plague not only did
humanity not really have a chance to
respond neither did Atlantis and so
before anybody even knew what was
happening suddenly all these Atlanteans
are being transformed like these
monsters looking things and then it's
hacking everything in sight and so it's
really just one of these you know just
kinda like run and flee For Your Lives
kind of situations now of course that
means the doors get open to Atlantis
those who make it and find safe refuge
and and mera kinda makes a promise to
this young kid named oh no and she's
gonna do everything within her power to
basically protect the place now this
leads directly into Batman making
contact with Mara because that's worthy
to bear in mind is once she became queen
of Atlantis then she became a part of
the Justice League
now she was kind of an interim for her I
guess she was kind of a not really an
honorary member but she was part of it
for a time she did join the Justice
League but it was it didn't really seem
to be a permanent thing at this point so
long as she's queen it'll be a permanent
thing and the reason why is because the
Justice League is an earth-based team
like that the the role the team serves
is to protect the earth and so because
of that like whoever it is is currently
ruler of Atlantis will be the person
that Justice League will have to work
with now Mara is queen of Atlantis for
the foreseeable future one because
Aquaman's missing and two because he
conceded the throne to her and plus
she's a she's a hero in and of herself
which means the Justice League will
reach out to her and that's exactly what
happens here Batman reaches out and says
look this is like an emergency broadcast
to anybody out there who happens to be
listening and like is not a not a weirdo
ssin creature the earth is being
conquered it's basically being drowned
life is being transformed into whatever
weird form this happens to be now
anybody who can answer they call answer
the call and in this moment mirror
responds the problem with this is that
Mara is running into the scenario that
Aquaman ran into and it's one of the
things that she was never fully able to
appreciate until this very moment when
it came to Aquaman being king of
Atlantis he was basically having to walk
this kind of tightrope on one half it
was his allegiances are to Atlantis you
know those who were in Atlantis were
Failte to him the other half
he's a member of the Justice League he's
part of the surface world and so he has
to do what's best for the service world
at the same time and the question that
was constantly being asked of him is if
you have to choose one which one do you
pick and that was the struggle of
Aquaman it was always trying to find a
way to choose both and mara is basically
finding this out the hard way using her
aqua kinetic powers
she's keeping these oceans at bay for
like plunging into Atlantis and
basically destroying the capital city
and in turn killing everybody in there
or at least turning them into those
weird ocean creatures while at the same
time kind of trying to organize a rescue
front for those within atlantis proper
who have not really been transformed yet
I mean the various people who were kind
of out there and so on and so forth
tears you know have many thousands of
people who were who were currently in
danger and only around 3,000 can
actually be rescued obviously around
5,000 can actually be rescued so she has
sir one Marshall those forces and get
those guys together and then on the
other hand try to figure out a way to
see if it's possible to fight with the
Justice League but she's given the
choice here Batman says look your
allegiances are to the world as a
superhero your allegiances to the world
as a member of the Justice League your
job is to protect the world mayor's
response is I am queen of Atlantis
Atlantis first the world's second but
Batman kind of speaks last week's reason
here it says yeah but of what use is
saving the Atlantis if there is no world
left to save if all that's left is you
and the response is then it'll just be
us and that's kind of the struggle here
that's the struggle that meera has to
face in this moment when Batman says
look this is how bad things are like
there's your perception of it being like
a global calamity and okay well you know
given enough time the Justice League
will save it here's how the world really
asked we're literally on our last leg
here there's almost nothing left to say
the world is drought like we need people
who have knowledge of the oceans we need
people who have any kind of superpower
whatsoever you're holding back the
oceans of the world is literally what
you're doing here if you do not join in
there's not gonna be anything left for
you to say you're gonna be here and then
eventually you'll be conquered and
that'll be the end of that and not only
that it's only a matter of time before
you give in before your body and your
mind can't handle holding back for what
the waters of the ocean in which case
you're gonna lose everything
and so what Batman is basically asking
of Mary here is to say look you're gonna
have to sacrifice Atlantis you're gonna
have to give up Atlantis you got to
sacrifice Atlantis and the people in it
for the greater good to save the world
and that's a hard ask that's a very very
big ask to come up with for one a newly
elected or against a newly appointed
queen and to a queen that cares so much
about her people as it was one of these
things because remember if she does this
from Mayer's perspective
does this if she gives up if she
sacrifices Atlantis and if she lets it
all go and then joins the Justice League
to save the world then the people of
Atlantis will see it as a betrayal they
elected heard of that position because
she was an outsider but because she's a
person who could be molded to become a
true queen of Atlantis somebody who
could actually serve the throne while
not giving too much concern to the
surface world she would be doing the
exact opposite and and really when at
the end of the day a king or queen
serves the pleasure of the people and so
if she does this as she turns against
Atlantis is she sacrifices it Gosha
fight alongside the Justice League saves
the world and then comes back that
people will turn against her and she'll
be exactly where it where Aquaman was
some period before when the people
turned against him and out stood him as
king that's the concern she has but at
the end of the day that concern is
basically a switch for her well there's
a massive explosion when the the
generators are taken down when the
waters come flooding in due to her
distraction and she's basically the sole
survivor the sole person who's not
transformed into one of these monsters
and that's what it's a matter of okay
well then the questions been solved for
me it's been taken care of for me don't
probably be some dope though I mean
those certainly be some things to answer
for the fact that she was you know
essentially even toying with the idea of
sacrificing Atlantis would be a lot of
chastising going on you know you could
never make that choice again you know
that kind of situation and so on but in
the moment it's basically just her the
problem with this is that where she's
trying to communicate with with Batman
where Batman's trying to communicate
with her the connection gets severed and
so in her mind she basically says
there's only one person left that can
basically save us they can help us here
there's only one person they can protect
us you know there is a person who served
as a you serve the throne of Atlantis
who ruled Atlantis and who knows the
oceans better than I do and almost as
well as Aquaman if we can find him and
if he's not transformed then he can
basically save us and so what she does
is travel to the highest tower and all
of Atlantis where this guy was in prison
she breaks in and we end up finding out
that his arm the ocean master the guy
who led the entire throne of Atlantis
revolt and this is kind of a big deal
because it's bringing his character back
who's basically hasn't really been seen
since really the the new 52 and it's
kind of curious as he what role he plays
because he's really he's very much a
gambit here is very much a card why if
it comes down to it we'll orme
try to retake the throne again that's
really the question that's being asked
here you know when this whole thing is
all said and done when it's all
basically fixed is or I'm gonna try to
take the throne back now of course or
I'm being invoked here is very much due
to the Aquaman movie I can almost
guarantee it I got was guaranteed it was
never really in 10
to bring him in until it was like he's
gonna be in the movies he got to feature
him somehow because in truth I don't
know exactly what he would do but it is
cool here and it is kind of interesting
because it throws in of what's very much
kind of like a wrench of the monkey work
so I'm yeah you know it throws it throws
a wrench of the works it's really what
it does it throws in kind of this this
variable that we didn't expect but could
potentially change everything we have no
clue what Elend up happening here but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]